[Música]
los sister ex han estado con nosotros
desde hace mucho tiempo son estos
pequeños secretos que los
desarrolladores se van poner en sus
juegos y nosotros amamos descubrir cómo
el punto de estos intereses bueno
obviamente estén ocultos en ocasiones es
difícil encontrarlos pero con el tiempo
y con la llegada de internet los
jugadores han vuelto inusualmente buenos
dedicados en contra nuestros intereses
lo que hace que un intelecto dure mucho
tiempo antes de que alguien lo descubra
pero algunos desarrolladores que lo
esconden demasiado bien y por más
dedicación de los jugadores se toma su
tiempo para ser aliado
[Música]
y primero vamos a gta 5 donde después de
dos años de que el juego fuera estrenado
se descubrió que no solo las marcadas el
siguiente número y osa llamar a un
contacto con el nombre teléfonos negros
que a pesar de su nombre tan sugestivo
lo que hace es crear una explosión
aleatoria y aparte de eso cuando llamas
la apariencia de tu teléfono cambia es
bastante raro de hecho
[Música]
hay muchas formas de ocultar un interés
pero esto fue algo un poco [ __ ] decir
verdad para encontrarlo en el racing 2
original si vas a la comisaría y dirigía
el escritorio de western interactúas no
pasaba nada pero si interactúas en
cuenta de seguidas 50 [ __ ] veces
imagina que discurrió histeria
interactuando 50 veces en todo esto como
subnormal no me jodas pero bueno si te
tomas el tiempo para interactuar las 50
veces encontramos una foto que al
revelar la verás que pertenece a rebecca
chambers una policía no ataque también
tuvo su propio juego en el remake y
siero algo parecido se encuentra en el
escritorio es que era una parte para el
arma de clero lyon y la foto en hd
rebeca y porque o es que te una foto
real con ropa muy pequeña
este secreto de halo 3 tardó bastante
porque en primer lugar no estaba
dirigido así los jugadores como
usualmente uno de los desarrolladores
puso un mensaje secreto en la pantalla
de carga del juego pero sólo aparecía si
tenían la consola con la fecha del 25 de
diciembre y mientras el juego cargaba
presionamos ambos sticks esto iba a ser
con la pantalla de carga con un anillo
en ella mostrará las palabras feliz
cumpleaños lowry la esposa del
desarrollador que puso el mensaje y
pensar que él concitó modo 6 casi 7 años
para ser descubierto
[Música]
en ponts out cuando te enfrentes a la
válvula en vez de tratar de golpearlo
una y otra vez a la antigüita puede
vencerlo una manera mucho más fácil solo
poniendo atención al público ya que en
el momento que el flash de la cámara de
este personaje de fondo se apague te
harás golpearlo en ese mismo instante
para no quererlos de un solo golpe
lo interesante es que este secreto no lo
descubrió ningún fanático del juego fue
el mismo presidente de nintendo satoru
iwata que en 22 años después de la
salida del juego en una entrevista
confesó este secreto tan bien guardado
[Música]
super smash brote no secreto que bueno
técnicamente es más un cliché que tomo
siete años para ser descubierto y es que
siguiendo una gran cantidad de complejos
pasos en el menú de selección de
personajes pasos que no voy a decir
porque son de verdad muy complicadas
después de numerosos pasos podrás jugar
como la master hand el enemigo final del
juego como dije esto más que un histeria
que son gays pero a quién le importa
[Música]
en 'batman arkham city' si vas a las
prisiones encontrarás un tipo encerrado
ahí el hombre calendario este tipo si lo
visitas durante todo el juego tendrá
institutos diálogos sobre crímenes que
cometió en fechas importantes como año
nuevo el día acción de gracias pero si
pones una fecha muy especial en tu
consola el 13 de diciembre de 2004 fecha
en la que la desarrolladora del juego
rocksteady fue creada visitas al hombre
calendario en esa fecha tendrán nuevos
diálogos que apuntaban a la última
entrega de la saga arkham night
a huevo
en donde podéis
work
por eso a ver
ya está quiero nació es que los en fruit
estaremos muy bien
esto
my way
ourense
te voy a decir batman
6 es comer
hago este tienen
si quieres acertijos que volverán tu
cabeza y tener no ser cada pista de
conocimiento que tienes te dirá dónde
tienes que ir a un juego de motos sí por
qué porque así trail es una serie con
una de los mejores intereses en la
historia de hecho tiene un historial que
quiero dedicarle un vídeo entero pero
center menos por ahora en files y desde
el 4 ministerio que tomó tres años para
ser resuelto pues a medida que juegas
por todos los mapas verás que hay cada
uno hay pistas para algo bueno después
de reunir todas las pistas y de un largo
largo trabajo de la comunidad se unieron
todas las partes del acertijo que quería
resolver las preguntas más importantes
de la vida recomendó que busque en es un
tema bastante interesante y difícil de
encontrar claro que es difícil resolver
pistas mientras manejas una moto y
tratas de no romper te la cara
[Música]
en splinter cell double agent tienes una
gran variedad de misiones pero ninguna
será tan enigmática y extraña como la
que te contaré en el nivel de la presión
desde contra una moneda de oro ocultas
dentro un cazador que es dispararle para
abrir luego de tomar la moneda de oro de
as dirigirte una máquina expendedora más
atrás en el nivel que al interactuar no
pasa nada pero si aciertas la moneda de
oro dentro de la máquina iniciarás el
estrés más divertido entre un sprinter
cell luego insertar la moneda librarás
una foca bebé llamada muffin la cual te
agradece por haberla rescatado y te
pedirá algo de comida después debes
encontrar un alcance creta con comida
para móvil luego de esto la foca que
rescataste te enviará una misión secreta
para rescatar a sus demás hermanos son
cinco focas bebés que debe rescatar en
total muffin pero ni bad y cookie y
vainilla cada una con ciertos requisitos
para rescatarlas luego una larga y
compleja misión créeme es compleja en
una pequeña cinemática se revela que las
focas son alienígenas y que jamás
olvidarán la ayuda que tú les brindas te
esta tierra este electo cuatro años para
ser descubierto y eso porque fue un
desarrollador frustrado de que no
encontraron su secreto quien salió
públicamente a revelarlo
y
en metal gear solid 3 este juegazo
después de haber pasado por muchas
aventuras enfrentarás al enemigo final
viene un francotirador legendario que
tiene más de 100 años pero que suele no
te engañe porque verás prepararte para
una dura batalla final donde deberás
usar todo lo aprendido durante el juego
si quieres derrotarlo el cabrón es duro
pero que no se nos olvide de quien es
del juego porque ya estas alturas ya
sabemos que cogimos un loco así que él
puso un secreto o unos cuantos en caso
de que quieras evitar la batalla final
con bien en el juego existen dos maneras
alternativas de acabar con tiene antes
de la batalla final
temprano el juego va en una parte donde
el anciano necesitará subir a un
helicóptero si el jugador ha adquirido
el rifle francotirador para ese punto lo
único que debes hacer es hacer zoom y
acabar con 10 en cuanto lo veas
la segunda manera de evitar la pelea
final es llegando normalmente al final
pero antes de que comience la batalla
deberás guardar el juego salir en tu
consola adelantar la fecha un año y de
nuevo entrar al juego donde lo dejaste
si haces todo correctamente cuando estés
en la batalla final encontrarás que tu
enemigo murió de vejez por esperarte
este secreto de kojima tomó cuatro años
para ser descubierto
como curiosidad si en vez de adelantar
la fecha un año solo le adelanta una
semana schneck se quedará dormido de la
batalla y por ende lo capturaran si este
juego está lleno de coimas
[Música]
gta 5 es uno de los juegos más
ambiciosos y lineales en recientes años
estrenado en 2003 de tomo nada más que
tres años para que descubrieran su
extraño secreto pues los jugadores
deberán descubrir el lugar y hora
exactos en donde deben encontrar unas
plantas de mas peyotes si el jugar las
comidas se transformaba en pie grande
pero no acaba ahí porque sencilla es que
pie grande rugir en lugares muy
específicos y vas a escuchar otro lío en
respuesta después de descubrir todas las
ubicaciones en las que pie grande de
vida rugir y al llegar al último lugar
descubrirás que quien te está buscando
de vuelta era el lobo adolescente y
deberás luchar a muerte con él y si lo
derrota estará compensarán con su piel
hoy
[Música]
finalmente en gears of war ya estamos
acostumbrados a los sister ex extraños
como la gallina hora de la muerte pero
pensar que en un juego así popular y con
una comunidad tan dedicada tomaría cinco
años para que descubrieran su último
secreto es genial haber para revelar
estos secretos debes encontrar otras
monedas muy pero muy bien escondidas y
es que las dos primeras casi ni se ven
pero si las encontrabas y les disparaban
a las tres tíos entrar en un juego
bastante conocido dog and take that hand
pero con locust en vez de patos después
de disparar a las tres monedas entraras
a una sala con una torreta y un lugar en
donde saldrán locos del suelo y tendrás
que dispararles antes de que caiga y lo
bueno es que te harán distintas
recompensas dependiendo de cómo lo hagas
increíble ecológico como quieres 3 salió
hace 8 años aún tuve esta clase de
secretos
[Música]
bueno creo que esto nos hace pensar que
tal vez nuestros juegos por más viejos
que sean tal vez aún tengan algunos
secretos escondidos quién sabe tal vez
haya otro grupo de enfoques bebé
esperando ser rescatadas en algún otro
juego en cualquier caso gracias por ver
el vídeo para más contenido así sigue el
canal créeme no te decepcionará hasta la
próxima
e
i
ah
sí
[Música]